last friday we had john stossel on right
and we spoke about miranda santa's
banning critical race theory and he
brought up a good point he's a
libertarian that it is that it is
slightly it could be taken as
totalitarian you know you're banning
this you're saying it's not allowed from
the top down et cetera et cetera if you
put the shoe on the other foot it could
be done with something else against you
you know it's always a show on the other
foot test is it up to desantis to make
that call or should he be pushing the
parents to to pay more attention to the
school boards to elect the right people
like what you're seeing in loudoun
county i mean is it up to desantis to
make that call to ban it or should he
let it play out amongst the voters
two things one
first amendment rights which stossel was
referring to it doesn't apply to the
government schools are part of the
government as i said so like people
decide voters decide to elect
legislators legislators make laws
education is enshrined in the law like
what kids have to be taught in school we
do have standards in florida state
standards that are prescribed by the law
as i was saying african-american history
is one of them we have a law in
holocaust education that you have to
teach it as it's a fact not to say that
it's the theory or it's disputed or
anything like that that would be illegal
you would lose your job if you were a
teacher and you said something like that
and so we have these laws for a reason
because again public education it's a
public good it's provided by the
government and so kids have the right to
learn facts and so to say that teachers
should have free speech to say whatever
they want in class while they're
government employees it's like saying
that i as a government employee should
be getting paid to campaign against
nicki freed or something which is not
allowed you know like there are
restrictions that you have as a
government employee you can speak freely
in your free time but you can't while
you're on the clock and especially while
you're teaching kids you can't say
whatever you want i mean there was a
teacher here in palm beach i believe who
said that the holocaust is a theory and
some people disagree that it actually
happened he was fired over it
not because he doesn't have free speech
rights but because he said it in class
to his students when he's a government
employee and you can't do that you're
not entitled to express your own opinion
in class if it's not um factual and if
it's not if there is a law about this
about what needs to be taught so that's
one thing the second thing is
discrimination is already against the
law if you're facing discrimination at
work for example from your employer if
you're facing discrimination
in university if you're a student and
you face racial discrimination or based
on gender or anything like that you have
the right to sue right and that's been
the law for a long time
um the types of things that are being
taught under the umbrella of critical
race theory
is discriminatory for example everyone
has probably heard the this kind of
hysterical example from coca-cola they
did a diversity training where they said
basically whiteness is bad try to be
less white as if you can change your
race and then they said whiteness like
meritocracy and competition it's forms
of whiteness now i don't believe that i
believe meritocracy means excellence and
anyone from any race can have that
quality it's not it's not tied to
whiteness it's not one specific race
that can only be so this type of thing
um it is discrimination and that's been
against the law for a long time so i
don't i don't agree with stossel's
points at all for those two reasons and
i think libertarians i agree with them
on certain things but i think they don't
know what time it is now with the left
taking over so many institutions from
business to um schools we need to
conservatives should use their lawful
power
in order to ensure
that the facts are taught yeah so you
know what my biggest challenge was what
stassel said about that
is
you can't he says well let the market
decide i said you can't move your kids
zip codes you're controlled when it's
statewide that's being taught let the
market decide on private school
that go forward open up a private school
and teach critical race theory 24 7
matter of fact i'd love a case study i
would love
for the democrats to fund opening up
schools that they teach heavy heavy race
theory in their private school and let's
see how many students pay how many
parents paid 30 grand a year for their
kids to go to that school i think it's a
great system if you think you're so
right and there's a market for it start
a school with the core foundation being
crt see if there's people that are
willing to pay money for it i think
that's a good idea public school is not
a marketplace of ideas and there are
some parts of this state where there's
no private schools so that that that was
my challenge but what stassel said is
you can't say let the markets decide you
can't do that when i'm a taxpayer and
you create a law i can't compete a
market decide like it's a whole remember
parents used to get caught because they
wanted their kid to go to the better
public school and they gave them mom's
address and then they got caught and it
happens all the time happens all the
time i'm like dude this you can't do
that kind of stuff so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]